depending on the poll Hillary Clinton is
either leading Donald Trump among women
55 to 35 or 53 to 41 the startling part
is that Trump has any number larger than
zero if you are a woman planning to vote
for him this question how much worse
does his record about women need to be
doesn't it bother you that Donald Trump
speculated again this month that all the
women who have come forward with sexual
allegations against him are doing it for
the money yet none of them seemed to be
suing him while he says he will sue them
all doesn't it bother you that he keeps
insisting that as he phrased it in the
last debate nobody has more respect for
women than I do yet when a pornographic
actress claimed he grabbed her Trump
said oh I'm sure she has never been
grabbed before there he goes
respecting women again doesn't that
bother you even if he didn't do anything
and she and the others are all lying
doesn't that bother you doesn't it
bother you that when a woman employee he
body shamed in public came out for
Hillary Clinton he accused her of also
being a pornographic actress disgusting
check out sex tape and past Alicia em
doesn't it bother you that before Alicia
Machado and before all those women and
long before that Billy Bush tape back in
March his campaign manager shoved a
woman reporter Trump said she had made
the story up and he hinted at
prosecuting her victory press conference
was over why is she allowed to grab me
and shout questions can i press charges
does it bother you that he allegedly
wanted to fire women who worked for him
at his Golf Club in Rancho Palos Verdes
California for not being quote pretty
enough doesn't bother you the days after
Anna Nicole Smith drop dead he went on
national radio and said she had the best
hair but she had the best face and the
best body now when she opened her mouth
it was different let's face it doesn't
it bother you that when his advocate
Newt Gingrich gets into an on-air
argument with a woman newscaster his
spokesman accuses her of attacking Trump
and makes the thinly veiled threat quote
watch what happens to her when this
election is over doesn't it bother you
that he dismissed one woman seeking to
become the first ever to be the
presidential nominee of his party why
can you imagine that the face of our
next president doesn't it bother you
that after he attacked a gold star
father who lost his son as his son
fought for this nation in Iraq for
criticizing him he then attacked a gold
star mother for not criticizing him none
of this bothers you when he claimed
American troops stole cash while serving
in Iraq when he said John McCain wasn't
a war hero because he got captured when
he said he had never asked God for
forgiveness if none of this bothers you
none of it none of it makes you think
twice about voting for this crude
abusive sexist disrespectful
non-religious man then I have just one
more question is the idea of a man like
this as president appealed to you
because it somehow makes a similar
misogynist in your own life seem more ok
I mean if there's a president jackass
does that make the mr. jackass you know
somehow more acceptable and he is a
jackass to women if you didn't know that
or you won't admit it listen to one last
thing the magazine Mother Jones has just
found this on the archives of a blog
Trump used to write for his infamous
Trump University this entry is dated
January 6th 2009 and it is about the
actress Kelly Preston it is pretty
pathetic on its face but after you hear
it I'll tell you why I think it by
itself makes Trump ineligible to be
taken seriously by any woman let alone
voted for by one I'll read it in full I
have always respected people who were
loyal and faithful which brings to mind
Kelly Preston a long time ago before I
was married I met Kelly Preston at a
club and worked like hell to try and
pick her up she was beautiful personable
and definitely had allure at the time I
had no idea she was married to John
Travolta in any event my track record on
this subject has always been outstanding
but Kelly wouldn't give me the time of
day she was very nice very elegant but I
didn't have a chance with her and that
was that when I later found out she was
married to John I liked and respected
her even more
some people have values that matter to
them and she is one of them her loyalty
was unwavering and I have always
remembered that about her being true to
someone is very close to being true to
yourself that's a
valuable attribute in today's world why
on earth was he blogging about the time
years before when he struck out with
Kelly Preston at a club what does the
arrogance of the phrase my track record
on this subject has always been
outstanding had to do with her this was
a blog post about Kelly Preston's son
dying Jett Travolta 16 years old a
seizure one a family vacation this
self-absorbed boasting about his
brilliance at picking up women was his
idea of a condolence note for the
devastating death of a 16 year old boy a
subject he finally gets around to in the
last of the 12 sentences he wrote I'm
sure she was a wonderful mother to Jett
and my thoughts are with her and her
family after their terrible loss no they
weren't his thoughts were about himself
his thoughts are always about himself if
you can still vote for a man like this
explain your reasons to your maker not
to me
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space